das ist wirklich mal ein spannender
perspektivwechsel eines forschungsteams
die fachleute haben nämlich festgestellt
dass unsere erde keineswegs die
optimalen bedingungen für leben bietet
stattdessen könnte es andere planeten
geben die viel paradiesischer sind ist
das vielleicht der nächste wichtige
schritt bei unserer suche nach
außerirdischen leben kriegs und science
fiction gibt die spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und activity
glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen klar ist da
auf unserer erde reichlich leben
existiert müssen die bedingungen für die
entstehung von leben ganz gut gewesen
sein
doch waren sie vielleicht gerade gut
genug oder waren sie sogar ideal für die
entstehung von leben auf diese fragen
gibt es keine klaren antworten denn
schließlich haben forschungsteams
weltweit keinen vergleich einen weiteren
beliebten planeten konnten wir bislang
eben noch nicht aufspüren welche
faktoren sind also entscheiden damit
sich leben bilden kann und welche sind
vielleicht gar nicht so wichtig wie wir
bislang angenommen haben braucht es
tatsächlich einen großen mond der für
gezeiten sorgt und hat die
plattentektonik einen entscheidenden
einfluss oder war es bei der ewe eben
ein äußerst seltenes oder gar
einzigartiges zusammenspiel an umständen
fragen über fragen auf die expertinnen
und experten weltweit keine klaren
antworten geben können
auch wenn die wahrscheinlichkeit für
außerirdisches leben mit jeder
entdeckung die astronomie teams machen
immer größer wird
die us astronomen stefan olsson hat in
diesem zusammenhang mal die perspektive
gewechselt in ihren modellen hat sie
zusammen mit ihrem team verschiedene
umweltbedingungen auf exo planeten
simuliert und dabei herausgefunden dass
die erde keineswegs das ideal da stellt
das us forschungsteam konzentrierte sich
dabei auf den faktor flüssiges wasser
denn dahingehend ist sich die fachwelt
einig flüssiges wasser ist die
grundvoraussetzung für die entstehung
von leben das ist jedenfalls der
aktuelle stand der wissenschaft doch
planeten mit ozean aus wasser bieten
keineswegs direkt super günstige
bedingungen allein die
strömungsverhältnisse haben schon einen
großen einfluss und so simulierten die
expertinnen experten ozean habitate auf
planeten mit verschiedenen
umweltbedingungen dabei nutzten sie eine
software namens
die von der nasa entwickelt wurde im
fokus der analyse standen aufwärts
strömung die tatsächlich lebens
entscheiden sein können denn sie sorgen
dafür dass nährstoffe aus der tiefe an
die oberfläche gelangen können foto
synthetisch aktive organismen könnten
somit vielen nährstoffen versorgt werden
und somit in der lage sein photosynthese
zu betreiben
dank der simulationen bezüglich
ozeanischer zirkulation kamen
letztendlich einige super spannende
erkenntnisse heraus die forschungen sind
jetzt in der lage ungünstige bis
optimale bedingungen zu simulieren
demnach ist der auftrieb und somit auch
die lebensfülle größer wenn der planet
langsamer rotiert wenn kontinente
vorhanden sind wenn der planet eine
dichtere atmosphäre hat das ergebnis hat
das forschungsteam sogar selbst
überrascht denn ja die erde ist demnach
nicht die nummer 1 also das ideal und
jahr auf anderen planeten könnte es
möglicherweise sogar paradiesischer sein
ist diese erkenntnis vielleicht der
nächste wichtige schritt bei der suche
nach außerirdischem leben eine antwort
auf diese frage können wir in der
nächsten zeit nicht erwarten denn die
derzeitigen teleskope reichen noch lange
nicht aus um die hypothesen von stefan
olsson und den kolleginnen und kollegen
zu überprüfen und im besten fall zu
untermauern
das james webb weltraumteleskop soll ja
in zwei jahren 2021 staaten gerade es
wurde es ja fertig gestellt und ist
jetzt bereit zum start doch auch dieses
riesen weltraumteleskop ist wohl nicht
dazu in der lage die faktoren von
stefanie bolzen und ihrem team zu
analysieren und das obwohl es mit seiner
auflösung die astronomie komplett
revolutionieren könnte das
riesenteleskop ist unter anderem
speziell dafür entwickelt worden
außerirdisches leben zu suchen
anders als das hubble teleskop das im
sichtbaren namen ultravioletten und
nahen infraroten spektrum sucht ist das
james webb teleskop ein supertalent im
infraroten bereich so kann es
beispielsweise die atmosphäre von
exoplaneten analysieren die wiederum
hinweise auf kleine tages leben geben um
die berechnung der aktuellen studie zu
überprüfen müssten wohl teleskope herr
die bislang nur in der theorie
existieren so zum beispiel wie optical
infrared survey telescope an dem die
nasa derzeit arbeitet hier mit könnten
forschungsteams
exoplaneten fotografieren und die
chemische zusammensetzung ihrer
atmosphäre und oberfläche bestimmen die
fachleute um stefanie bolzen jedenfalls
setzen große hoffnungen auf entwicklung
in diesem bereich und mit neu
entwickelten weltraumteleskopen solche
möglicherweise paradiesischen planeten
ins visier zu nehmen es scheint so als
könnten wir optimistisch sein dass die
suche nach leben immer weiter in die
richtige richtung voranschreitet doch
was wäre dann eigentlich wenn wir dann
doch auf solchen paradiesischen planeten
nicht fündig würden dann suchen wir
weiter und zwar nach planeten die leben
vielleicht noch mit mühe und not möglich
machen
bisherige studien hat nämlich gezeigt
dass sich leben möglicherweise auch auf
planeten entwickeln könnte die alles
andere als ideale bedingungen dafür
bieten auf monden beispielsweise die
ihre energie dadurch erhalten dass sie
von der anziehungskraft des
riesenplaneten um den sieg reisen
durchgeknetet werden wie der saturnmond
enceladus untersuchungen hatten
nahegelegt dass sich leben dort zwar
komplizierter gestalten könnte als auf
der erde aber durchaus möglich ist gibt
es leben auf titan der planet ist
nämlich ganz anders als die erde
trotzdem könnte es dort leben geben
anklicken anschauen und astro comics tv
abonnieren sehr cooler kanal bis dann
bleibt dran